foreign
foreign foreign
the three Muslims today we're joined
with the three Muslims
me myself and I alhamdulillah until
fight and on home can get back inshallah
I'm just going to be doing this solo for
a little bit uh inshallah they should be
back soon hope you guys doing well
inshallah let me know how you guys are
doing in the chat and let me get you
guys started with the itinerary for
today
so first and foremost do you guys want a
stream with Sonny fast and his mom
because they're down to do another
stream inshallah let me know if you guys
want that comment down in the comment
section Sunny fast and his mom
next Bismillah we're going to talk about
Aiden Ross speaking about Islam Iraq to
a small clip but there's I think a
longer version of that or a longer you
know discussion that he had
so inshallah we're going to discuss that
dissect it break it down and I'm gonna
give my thoughts on that and then later
we have not one but two shahadas today
two lovely Brothers accepting Islam
alhamdulillah
last week actually we were supposed to
have a brother accept Islam on stream
but um it just didn't work out I forgot
about it and he didn't join uh the the
the time so we accepted Islam
alhamdulillah afterwards
uh just in private me and him so without
further Ado I could see everyone wants
uh Sonny fast and his mom to come on
again
brother Muhammad is like why not
foreign all right
so without further Ado we don't have
much time because the first brother is
going to take a shahada around 6 45 so
let's just start with the reaction
let me pull up the file here
and let's begin came down right now you
said what extra threats with me and came
down right now okay was it like an alien
yeah basically no basically everybody
just popped up the apocalypse is what
you're saying right no or anybody just
popped up
where they came from it was Tim there
was [ __ ] 20 feet tall right and they
had powers like they could just move
[ __ ] do this and like he said
I am the I'm the guy I'm believing I've
I've I've returned I believe in that
everybody's gonna believe me God right
because in the Quran so that's gonna
happen huh so so that's what I want to
say so so I want to say this snaggy ball
okay so immediately Brothers he has puts
forth this hypothetical I think with the
with the point I'm trying to show if
someone comes and has supernatural
abilities you would be believe their God
I would not believe their God
I would say the very fact that they are
on Earth
and they have a limited size a limited
height and they're doing certain things
even if it's like Supernatural whatever
I wouldn't say they're God if they said
I'm a messenger from God or like God
sent me and gave me abilities okay
that's one thing but the very fact that
they're on Earth proves that they're not
God because they're they're all of a
sudden they're contingent you know and
the fact that they're even
extraterrestrial extraterrestrial in
what sense that they are from somewhere
else in the universe right so being from
somewhere else in the universe you're
still contingent on the universal that
person or that thing that alien cannot
be God so now we're talking about the
Quran bro a lot of stuff that's gonna be
like a creature that looks like God he's
gonna bribe me to thinking that he's
gone but he's not God but why would God
want to fool us though
thank God the Bible says the same thing
the Antichrist return Antichrist right
um have you guys seen the movie This is
the End
yeah you saw where like they get sucked
up it's called it's called the job
they're saying right now so yeah okay
but they call the apocalypse here right
well no sorry they call the Apocalypse
in Christianity right
the end the like is that what you're
talking about
now you're saying like the creatures are
gonna come to like Earth and pretend
he's gone oh yeah
y'all not getting me though why would a
[ __ ]
Hassan is like the world so that's why
you're supposed to be in your Bible is
that what you're supposed to know like
all right so you should know that but
God shouldn't get you if you don't
[ __ ] know if I don't know but just
wasn't no that's you're supposed to know
so because God basically God will never
bribe you to do something that's against
the religion so what type of Rob is a
[ __ ] gonna say what is he gonna say
something you want he could bring back
your dead relatives yeah
um
this is actually very interesting this
is very very interesting because we
actually know that the Judd will have
limitations there will be things that he
can only do once right for example the
Hadith that mentions that there will be
a man who basically like Rebels against
the job he says I don't believe that
you're God and then the gel will cut him
in half and put him back together
and then he will ask now do you believe
I'm God and the man will say now I know
for a fact that you're not God and I
know for a fact that you are the
Antichrist you are the Jal
and why does he say this he said because
I know you can only do that once you
can't do it again so he challenges him
you know cut me in half again and pull
me back together again do it again
he said he the child will only be able
to do it once so he's limited so what is
tricks and deception and so on and so
forth maybe Allah will give him Powers
whatever Allah
and the prophet salaam made it very
clear actually I believe there's a
Hadith that said every single Prophet
warned their people about the day of
judgment and about the dead about the
Antichrist subhanallah so this is
something that you know you see in
Judaism you see in Christian actually
don't see
I don't know if they don't believe in
Antichrist or if they believe that it
was Jesus but regardless you see it in
Christianity you see in Islam so on and
so forth so and back to what I said
about the aliens and so on and so forth
if a man is coming and he's a man he's a
human being or he's an aliener he's a
physical thing and he's saying I'm God
he's contradicted himself
God who is not the physical thing is now
a physical thing saying I am God God
that's not a limited thing it's not a
limited thing saying I'm goding
you know it's many ways to debunk that
kind of claim so when the digital comes
he says I am God and you just have to
look at him say listen you're a
hunchback broad shoulder one eye a thing
with a cafe on his forehead how are you
God
Muslim apology says there's not your
question Judaism for clearing that up uh
for me and for the people about
but let's get back to the video okay do
y'all okay and then the Quran does it
talk about how
basically
um Satan has the meaning of Earth he's
what he's basically the god of dessert
okay so in the Bible it like it talks
about how basically God gave Satan the
meaning of the Earth right yeah and he's
basically got a dessert
right
so never mind that's the dude I don't
[ __ ] it bro yeah
he was he was an angel and then he
became an antichrist
yeah but he got passed down to Earth but
I know but like [ __ ] people think he
got carried down to Hell no he got
killed something no yeah I know if
there's a scene
do you believe in Helen um Helen heaven
and okay okay because you know Judaism
you don't believe there's no help
just to jump in we don't believe that
shayathon has dominion over Earth we
actually believe that Allah
put the human beings on the earth to
give them Dominion to make them she says
I've put basically I will put you know a
creation of human beings on Earth as a
hilafa or he said I'll put a new enough
on Earth essentially he announced that
to the angels yeah there's no hell
because all Jews are promised in the
promised land uh Abraham uh no that's
that's how it is I don't like also fun
fact there is no exact like depiction or
or you know demonstration or explanation
of Hellfire in you know the Old
Testament but they do have the word
jahannam which in Arabic uh is is you
know Hellfire basically
well genome is like a beast specifically
but um
yeah I mean also Hellfire I guess I
don't know I don't really know too much
it's weird what if you're a bad if
you're a bad person what do you go in
your religion yeah
okay but that's nothing what what the
[ __ ] is bad because good and bad is a
human construct you know what I'm saying
I feel like something that's where we go
what's bad now it wasn't bad back in the
day you're right it's changing I agree
with you weed and [ __ ] like you talking
about we detect humans what's good at
that okay like we killing
here's the thing about the crown that's
why I like all the prom I don't smoke
weed this way what I like about the
crown a lot a lot of this stuff that's
in the crown is applying to today that's
true a lot like everything that's like
prohibited in Islam has a great like
it's happening like it's it's it's
um you know what I mean so
okay before I move on to the Box he's
talking about the Caba I assume
um but before we move on to that Zia has
mentioned that the thing about morality
good and evil and that stuff is the
human construct it's not a human
construct if okay I'll put it like this
if God exists then it's not a human
construct it's up to God to tell us
objectively what is good what is bad
what is you know evil and so on and so
forth moral and immoral but if God does
not exist then it's 100 subjective
and this is actually why you need God if
you believe that there should be Justice
and there should there is good and evil
so on and so forth you need to believe
in God if you believe that there needs
to be people brought to Justice you need
to believe in Allah you need to believe
in the day of judgment if you want to
make sense of suffering in the world you
know evil in the world if you want to
make sense of it there has to be a God
people like to put it like uh people
like to say that if God exists wiser
evil wise or suffering Habibi one
evil without God you can't even Define
what evil is secondly
without God you cannot even make sense
of your suffering you're suffering is
suffering exists regardless you know
with God at least you can make sense of
the suffering and we know people suffer
for different reasons and that stuff but
back to the main point you know good and
evil these are things that only God can
tell us you know what is and what isn't
good and evil without goddess Yani or I
think this I think that
um
n-a-z-i Germany you know believe
something else
how can you prove they're wrong without
God
you know it's it would be impossible yes
box that everybody
so so they say it's something about this
[ __ ] told me that planes can't
go across and it's just like a [ __ ]
disappearance of [ __ ] no no no no no no
yeah
bro is he talking yeah
is he talking about the Bermuda Triangle
is he talking about the Bermuda Triangle
Man
[Laughter]
um
it's like a big ass black box and
everybody okay Molly
the West West Africa
okay so okay as an after I'm curious
like
because you know traditionally
we don't practice religions to we
practice spirituality you vote on
science and religion was basically
forced upon us like when we got
colonized by literally like it wasn't
like
preached through like Jehovah Witness
knocking on your door like they
literally came down destroying Villages
killing cheese like it was no choice it
was forced upon us that's only true for
Christianity that is 100 only true for
crescendi Islam as far as I know did not
do such a thing because it's prohibited
there's no compulsion in religion you're
not allowed to go in and put anything
that someone's head and force them to
become a Muslim but when you look at
what Constantine did in Africa he
basically forced and coerced people to
accept Christianity Islam did No Such
Thing Islam basically spread all
throughout Africa but not by force the
other expansion Wars and that stuff but
we never force people to accept the snow
uh even if we would kind of take the
minion over that land
um there was no such thing you know as
like harassing the people or attacking
them or you know r-a-p-e
to those people there's no such thing
and then furthermore down the line if
you look at the current uh cross
Atlantic or transatlantic slavery what
happened is they basically took them and
they forced Christianity upon them you
know what I mean so a lot of you know
Africans in in North America
or in in the UK for example who are
Christian
it's very possible that they were Muslim
Once Upon a Time and they're only
Christian because their ancestors who
were brought over here and you know
forced to be slaves they were forced to
adopt crescendia as well so it's uh he
actually brings up a really good point
I just want to emphasize that the
Muslims did not do this it was only the
Christians so like what are yo what are
yo like what's your sentiments on life
on that
um
to be honest I just think
I don't know bro I just think Islam is
the right religion in my opinion
okay do you think that because that's
how you was that's all you know to be
honest without it I still think that's
the religion because everything that's
like that's said in the Quran years ago
is literally happening now years ago
like years like so yeah but do you
understand spirituality
I'm very big on spiritual that's what I
believe in now mainly over everything to
be honest spirituality you know it's big
on that [ __ ] so what is the Quran saying
now what do y'all keep saying okay I'm
saying it right now the Quran the Quran
what the [ __ ] is the Quran saying you
gotta be careful bro I know I know you
can't you can't really say okay I never
said this yeah
I see people say you say the same thing
about the Bible too though
it is the Bible is too yeah it's
honestly notorious too the tour is the
Old Testament so the Torah is what
happened before the Bible Holy Bible and
um they're very very similar it's just
different people write it and write in
the book but that's what I'm saying
that's why when you look at all
religions
down so why the [ __ ] you can't have your
own story what's wrong with that [ __ ]
be living my goddamn life yo what the
[ __ ] I want to do and the [ __ ] say God
damn be Lou was that [ __ ] when he was
hurt he had problems doing this he had
problems doing that but he was still
that [ __ ] and he died and that [ __ ]
lived happily ever after you know what
I'm saying what's wrong with that but I
feel like religion
I mean the problem with that is it's
fictional and you know what I was
watching the video that blogging
theology put out recently with Dr Ali
atai and he literally says that that's
exactly what the you know the people who
had any kind of authority did whoever
authored the god the gospels Mark
Matthew Luke and John and Paul himself
they literally took like Greek folklore
they took Greek tales and basically made
Jesus the protagonist in those stories
or made Paul the protagonist in the
stories like the whole the whole tale of
Paul persecuting Christians and then he
sees a light and it's God Jesus Christ
and he says you know something along the
lines of like kicking in the gonads like
like how do you kick me in the gonads or
something something like that there's a
Greek story before I believe before the
time of Jesus that had that same exact
thing it had basically a a uh a God Son
of God thing
um incarnated and basically there was
this person who was persecuting believe
in that God and then that God appeared
in the form of a light and then said
that same exact phrase in Greek you know
something about kicking him in the
gonads I suggest you go watch the full
video but that's literally exactly what
the Christians did you know
um even a crucified the crucified son
and so on and so forth incarnated and
like eating drinking the blood of Jesus
and and eating the Flesh of Jesus and so
on and so forth all these things existed
uh with pagan origins so I mean that's
the problem with it it's fictional
whereas when you look at you know the
original Torah the original gospel the
Quran as it stands I don't want to say
the original because we have the
original alhamdulillah you know it's
based on what God has revealed to the
prophets
why are people saying be careful and
like I don't know it's bad to talk about
like balance the [ __ ] up religion
yeah I feel like I can just balance it
up but I feel like I don't know bro I
feel like it's not bad to talk about
we're being very specific all religion
is beautiful it's yeah I'm not saying
I'm not all religion is beautiful I
don't know we're not disrespecting any
religions like I'm saying it over and
over again every religion has its own
comparisons and similarities in all of
them it's crazy most of it had the same
belief but emotional yeah like the most
of them do most of them so majority
actually
religion is to control
the spirit gonna talk to you bro do what
your spirits say bro hey like if you
think about him it's like [ __ ] what if
some people's Spirits her spirit tells
them to go off someone
then what
if my spirit says to go off your spirit
is it just like a battle of the spirits
then
we need something objective as human
beings you know we need something
evidential self-evident even
now something from the divine
to really make anything of life you know
good evil purpose suffering objectivity
and all that stuff and you know it's
actually very
this panel is crazy because Allah says
in the Quran have you seen the one who
takes his own nests his own self his own
soul his own desires The Scholar say
means their vain desires to eat and to
to have intercourse with so so and so
and all this stuff have you seen the
person who takes their desires as their
God
you know they take their desires as a
god meaning and it's I'm not hitting on
my brother you know this is what he
believes that's his prerogative that's
okay that's no worries but this is what
it leads to you're basically you know
what is the spirit how do you how are
you how's your spirit talking to you
literally you know you get hard you're
like oh I want to be with this woman you
get hungry oh I want to eat this and eat
that that's literally it's it's more
animalistic than anything
so
we need something from the Divine and
inshallah you know we we do invite Aiden
onto the podcast though we're gonna see
if we can reach out to him or his
manager but uh we do invite him on insha
Allah hopefully we'll be able to uh
speak with him America like the founding
fathers of America wasn't even
Christians they weren't where were they
it was Freemason bro like it wasn't
worshiping Jesus
what exactly is a Freemason
s
that's different
that's LD
the religion I feel like that [ __ ] I
believe it I believe it and everyone
says everyone's saying chill now
everyone's saying stop now
what's with the chat I don't get it
what's with the chat why are they act
like this is some like crazy thing if
you talk about it you're gonna be you
know is God's Gonna Smite you or
something bro it's relaxed like relax
you're talking about religion talking
about God talking about which way of
life which religion is true why are
people telling them to chill I don't see
a reason for people saying chill other
than they have a really weird
understanding of religion or they're
extreme in the sense that you cannot
talk about it or they literally don't
want people to talk about Islam because
like they know it's the truth and they
don't want people to accept the snap
I don't know why people are so against
it
but you see how everybody's saying chill
because they scared of it yeah that's
like that's what I'm saying
they have the whole population
practicing a religion
big thing about it what's the number one
I don't care bro please
what's the lowest form of uh what's the
lowest frequency
as far as what the lowest form of
frequency
I don't even know about frequencies like
that is not music out of frequency
it's literally fear right that's what I
have right now exactly large form of
frequency fear probably what is religion
what is our relation religion based on
fear fear
[ __ ] are you a let me ask you a question
wait what
all religion is based on fear
I actually don't think there's a single
religion on the face of the Earth as
like at least the mainstream ones I
don't think there's a single religion on
the face of Earth that's based on fear
Judy has so much Judaism based off of
the one God
what is what is Christianity based off
of
they would probably say the one God I
would say the sacrifice and and the
crucifixion and resurrection of Jesus
Christ believing in Jesus died for your
sin and some people would say you know
Grace and good works as well what is
Islam based off of
there's no one worthy of worship except
for Allah
where is the fear in that yeah there are
aspects of if you do bad it will be
punished but there's aspects of that in
the law as well like look I can't go off
somebody I don't like without the fear
of being put either you know to um
offing myself or in jail the rest of my
life
so I mean fear is necessary fear is what
stops people from doing heinous things
and I don't see why you know that would
be a bad thing per se you Islam because
are you Islam because of the fear of
what happened if you don't act a certain
way or because that's just who you are
same with Chris same with Christians
what is all Christian Christianity based
on they're scared of
going against it
I actually think Christians are are
arrogantly confident that they're going
to heaven I think they're arrogantly
confident I don't think they're scared
of Hell bro if they're scared of Hell
they'd accept the stem I think they're
arrogantly confident thinking that
they're going to go to heaven
that's one of their arguments against
Islam oh we know we're going to heaven
you guys don't know so prove it so I
don't think they're really fearful and
that's that's literally fear is what
they like is what's used to control you
it's the lowest form of vibration more
frequency but low-key our [ __ ] is like a
it's like a former like it's like a
lifestyle bro it's like high schools to
live at the same time like it's like the
form of Lifestyle it's not really like a
religious religion it's like a lifestyle
so I believe it like it's like a
lifestyle that you have to do to be a
good person you know what I'm saying so
it is is it national Islam the same
thing relation Islam yeah it should be
like what fur counting them is
Farrakhan y'all know what I'm talking
about y'all might know what I'm talking
about
is it like two different type of Muslims
yeah
what did Neil just say and you'll Anil
just said Nation of Islam is not the
same thing yeah okay oh you don't know
what that is oh is it differently
completely believe I see it's too
different yeah I don't want to talk
about that I don't know what that is I
know what I believe in them
ain't nothing wrong with that because if
you mislead if you get like false
submission to as bad as like that's like
a crazy sense I don't want to talk about
that because I don't know yeah
bro
[Music]
I have a good people around me bro I
like to I like y'all bro I'm not ready
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know this [ __ ] for 24 hours llama I
mean yeah yeah yeah bro I feel it though
[ __ ] bro I I'm glad everybody like
you're saying can [ __ ] talk about it
though
they're also excited like five minutes
ago now she's dead look at all and
they're like
man look what religion does to people
man look what religion does
I can't wait for them to um pick it up
without being like
you know like [ __ ] oh it's
scary
[Music]
Aiden Habibi Aiden there's no reason to
be scared
all you need to do except Islam why
would you need to be fearful
what like Muslims are the I'd say the
only people on the face of the Earth
and especially if we look throughout
history
who they weren't really scared of of you
know passing even if it was in a bad way
like on the battlefield fighting in a
war they weren't scared of that's how
Islam spread so beautifully it like
exploded in you know in the Middle East
and it went uh you know to the borders
of China and and everywhere throughout
Africa and and all throughout Europe
is because these people
they weren't scared there's nothing to
fear I only fear Allah
and I only need to please Allah Allah is
the only one worthy of My Worship my
obedience
so let me you know basically live in a
way that's pleasing to him
so
there's nothing to be scared of bro this
is a good thing Insha'Allah and if
you're scared
um you're probably just you know you're
missing a bigger piece of the puzzle
it's scary because there's stuff I want
to say because it's crazy bro I feel I
feel like all four got something
different like we
no no believe it you know you know what
I'm just trying to say right now right
I don't know
real [ __ ]
I mean what are you Christian right no
are you not going to just think I
believe in the career I listen to myself
bro like my spirit bro you're spiritual
tell me to do it bro I'm gonna do your
intuition that's what you mean intuition
bro I feel like I'm me bro I like I said
the Bible [ __ ] I don't I ain't never son
of Quran Brian never lay hands on it
never seen it on Google pics none of
that you know what I'm saying let me
tell you what happens when you you
listen to your soul
listening to your solely intuition what
is that it's literally anything you were
taught growing up anything that you're
taught growing up that is programmed
into you subconsciously that you
presuppose that it's good you presuppose
that it's true that's what you end up
falling back on for example we live in a
secular liberal capitalist Society
so your fundamental values are going to
be liberal they're going to be secular
they're going to be capitalistic they're
going to be democratic
these are your values deep down living
in the West
and until you really investigate these
things and consciously think about maybe
I should agree or disagree with it
you're going to fall back on those
things
and that's why there's a huge Narrative
of you know you know any way of life is
okay if anyone believes this religion
that's true and if they believe that
religion that's true as well and all
religions are true and this this is just
this is secular liberal garbage I'm
sorry not everything can be true people
can believe what they want okay go for
it but this whole notion of no I'm gonna
listen to myself and I'm true and you
can listen to yourself and you're true
and uh where does it lead you again it
goes a lot of the question what if
someone's soul is telling them to go off
someone and go steal and go whatever
because that's things we like as human
beings right we don't like someone
sometimes we want to get rid of them
you're hungry sometimes you want to eat
and if you can't afford food you go and
steal or sometimes you just want
something nice you can't afford it so
you go and you steal it
that's the people's Soul telling them to
do that so why would that be something
that you know is good and should be
listened to
I would say it's the opposite actually
your soul needs to be restrained and it
needs to be your be purified and
cleansed through the remembrance of the
one who created you and what that
Creator tells you is good and evil
we're gonna take a little break for a
super chat from brother laith says peace
be upon you all this seems Aiden is well
on his way to being a Muslim Allah the
best of planners take care everyone
to my man and inshallah you know all
guidances from Allah
Rami you have changed my mindset like
three times from the start of this
podcast
wt-h LOL may Allah bless you I hope
that's in a good way inshallah okay I
don't really know what you see but far
as me
like I said I'm about my spiritual [ __ ]
it's something bro cause I I I'm telling
you I'd have like God didn't like
whether it was God whether the Creator
was the spirit I don't know what it was
because I never met the spirit in person
nothing like that but like I say brother
had times were like bro
or [ __ ] wasn't supposed to be here keep
it a whole hundred you know what I'm
saying Brody got shot at before look
back bullet hole right where my head was
at bro you know what I'm saying but it's
just like damn guy you got my back
that's crazy so I just believe like
whatever you feel me I know what you're
saying to me and that's all that matters
at the end of the day because I'm not
nobody else right and that's just what
it is what about you you Christian no no
children
yeah
look yeah
people people be forgetting they
probably don't even know the Bible
was it's a curated book you know what
I'm saying like the
oh you interrupted this flow man see the
current Bible everybody like refers to
when they try to defend Christianity
literally has missing like
the original like there's so many books
that was taken out of the Bible
facts so it changed over time hell yeah
that's the King James version probably
one of the most trans the the most
mistranslated version of the Bible you
know what I'm saying
you see with the Colossus the first time
was made never changed it's been the
same since it was amazing yeah so that's
why I think we kind of like credit give
me the Quran I think zayaz I think he's
a very fair person I think he's very
fair I think he I think all of them are
very new to this discussion they're very
new to this field and since it's not
talked about in their realm because
they're all like influencers right this
stuff is not talked about in their field
a lot it has picked up alhamdulillah
ever since Andrew take accepted Islam
which I think is a is a phenomenal thing
but you know they're new to this
discussion so obviously you know there's
going to be a bit of ignorance on on
their part and some things and you know
may Allah guide them and and you know
guide them to Islam Franklin I mean um
but I I do think that that they are fair
people especially in Aussie as I'm
shocked that he's fair to say that about
the Bible and to give credit to the
Quran
um for being preserved oh that's what
they say that's what they say man he
brought it down to us yeah one of the
ages brought it down to us and it just
never changed ever since
and you got a copy of it or something or
yeah it's a book it's like it's like a
book yeah I mean I'm just asking [ __ ]
like a copy or how does it so it's like
an old ass piece they got a new version
they got they got new versions yeah
it's like a book in Arabic you just read
you got everything like everything you
want to find out from the Quran
everything no matter what everything say
that
that's not a person if you read it could
drive you crazy because it's so scary I
know I don't want to say it
the whole vibe changed from the whole
tone of the discussion just changed it
ain't scared
from here
nah bro I don't feel like nobody wrong
[ __ ] you're gonna do you bro it's your
belief that's all I'm saying how the
[ __ ] you gonna be wrong bro
[ __ ] this is I I I actually think he
proved my point exactly what he just
said prove my point exactly that is pure
liberalism everyone do you everyone
maximize the freedom of the individual
everyone do whatever they want to do and
that thing is true yeah if you want to
believe in a a fairy tale Pony God that
is true and if you want to believe in
the one Crater of the heavens and the
Earth with no Partners or sons of
Associates then that is also true
you know it doesn't make sense
you're wrong like I said I feel like we
all four ain't on the same page oh God
are we not but like no we are though we
are no no no no no we all believe in
high Pride okay so that's the thing but
we are all we are all four on the same
page I know that for a fact it's just
different from the spiritual being yeah
up top yeah it's different it's
different it's different way it's
different ways to get there but it's the
same concept 100 I could say that I
think 100 100 like I'm I'm telling you
you're actually really [ __ ] smart
yeah
no no like Zeke actually knows but like
even the new year yeah bro it's not even
the real New Year people think Jennifer
for very first of the New Year it's not
the real New Year I know that too yeah
first we got only two we got two um
holidays what is it called yeah
animal
you sacrificed animals yeah bro
damn it goes like the slaughterhouse let
me kill it you kill an animal before
yeah bro what kind uh lamb goat sheep
you have to eat it yeah
with your hands bro we cook it yeah
so what we kill a lamb or we kill
animals
that's normal bro that's what you do
when I was back in Africa because back
because they don't do a certain prayer
that we do it before we eat like we got
to kill a certain way or it's not
allowed so we gotta do it ourselves so
why was Old Egypt like I said Egyptian
like you sacrifice humans and [ __ ]
yeah them [ __ ] back then
just sacrifice humans and [ __ ] I think
still to this day we ain't gonna act
like it ain't [ __ ] here but pretty
sure that's like
Satanism or occultism
I mean what they used to say then
remember that time they'd be like we're
gonna sacrifice this [ __ ] but if the
sun rise on this day we ain't gonna
sacrifices [ __ ] he's he's holy or some
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying I know
y'all just started movies and [ __ ] I
don't know if it's movies just
propaganda type [ __ ] it's probably
propaganda yeah you know what I'm saying
I don't know [ __ ] I wasn't there you
know what I'm saying but [ __ ] so what is
the point point of living
damn that's one [ __ ] question what's
the point
if if you all believe in the higher
power you believe in that you're not
supposed to be here that this [ __ ]
doesn't matter why we're here you know
what I believe yeah I believe this this
life is a test man is he going you're
gonna make it a hell you're gonna make
it happen depending on how you are on
this Earth I like that here's what I
believe and I believe that everyone on
Earth serves the same purpose but what
is heaven that's where you get rewarded
if you be a good person here there's
certain like levels of Heaven We Believe
Zeke I believe that everything on I
believe everything you do here everyone
has a different purpose on Earth but I
believe that the overall purpose of our
like our beings we're all meant to kind
of like help other people reach it like
the the um kind of like the uh the same
belief
that bro boom he nailed it he just
nailed it bro he just explained dawa
what dawa is in a nutshell and our
purpose our purpose in life is to
worship one God to worship one Creator
and the brother in the white you know in
the white pants he's right as well it's
a test Allah says in the Quran he did
not create Jin kind or mankind except to
test who is best indeed or who is good
indeed
so what are good deeds and what does it
mean to worship Allah well to associate
no partners with them and all that stuff
and to obey him and what does he say to
do he tells us to go and invite other
people to the truth because there's
always going to be non-muslims there's
always going to be disbelievers right
so we go and we invite them to the truth
of Islam that's exactly what he just
said there's a belief that is true and
that is good and our duty in life is to
help other people reach that same truth
that's what the prophet did and he
trained you know Abu Bakr and um
and and all these beautiful sahaba may
Allah be pleased with them trained all
them and what should they do within a
few Decades of the death of the Prophet
peace be upon Him Islam expanded like I
mentioned to the borders of China Africa
Europe and basically all over
subhanallah Islam the expansion of Islam
was is a phenomenal point in history
it's not given enough clout to be honest
it's not given enough attention there's
nothing on the face of the Earth that
spread that fast without forced
conversions without Force if you look at
what Christianity did maybe they spread
and whatever yeah but a lot of the time
they force people literally they
abducted people and said this is now
your belief
and he said there was no such thing for
example when the Muslims conquered
khorasan they allowed people to still
worship idols and be pagans
they they didn't stop them but over time
people just accepted Islam because they
saw how beautiful it was it's always the
truth and I think the biggest thing we
could take from this I'm going to stop
it here because the brother's gonna give
a shahada soon the biggest thing that we
could take from this is although all
four of them might disagree on on a few
things here and there they all agree on
what point
they all agree
that there is one Creator worthy of
worship there's one crater all of them
know that deep down
from the Muslim to the confused one to
the one who wants to be spiritual they
all believe in one Creator why is that
it's because human beings before we came
on this Earth Allah asked us to testify
am I not your lord and we we said yes
you are our Lord you are Allah you are
our God
and Allah created us and put us on this
Earth with a fitra knowing exactly that
and that's why no one on the face of the
Earth can ever truly be an atheist
they can claim they are they can't
substantiate it and I believe genuinely
all atheists deep down inside know that
God exists I genuinely believe that and
there was a study done in Oxford a
university and that they they
demonstrated that as well they went to
young kids of all different ages and
different backgrounds and they ask them
all do you believe in God or a higher
being or Creator they all said yes
or at least the vast majority as far as
you know but as far as what I've heard
is basically everyone
was born with that
so alhamdulillah
I think at the end of the day the truth
and this is what Allah says in the Quran
right the truth is clear and distinct
from falsehood and when truth comes
false advantages if I tell you you know
if you couldn't see my hat right now and
I said my hat is green my hat is green
my heart is green and I did this you're
like bro that's white what the heck are
you talking about you can no longer
believe that it's green because you've
seen for yourself the evidence is very
clear
so same thing when it comes to you know
Islam and with truth of religion and so
on and so forth
and once you're given the evidence
Yani that's it you cannot argue against
it
vibe so
that being said brother Jared are you
ready to accept the Sim if you are just
turn on your camera inshallah and I will
bring you into the stream so we can get
started I think I am two minutes late
or I'm just gonna bring you up
yo my man Jared how you doing good man
how are you I'm good I'm good are you
excited I am actually all right amazing
so without delaying any longer I'm just
gonna ask you a few questions they're
very simple not trick questions don't
worry
um just to make sure your your
fundamental beliefs are online and then
we're going to take the shahada and you
will accept the snap so firstly do you
believe that there is only one God
worthy of worship 100 and do you believe
in the angels of God that he describes
in the Quran yes and do you believe in
the prophets and The Messengers that God
has sent to the world yes and do you
believe in the books and the Revelation
that God sent with them like the the
original Torah the original gospel the
Quran and so on and so forth 100 perfect
and do you believe in Divine you know
Destiny or decree from God yes sir and
do you believe in life after death in
the day of judgment 100
perfect beautiful so alhamdulillah
that's perfect I'm just going to share
my screen so you can follow along
as we go so you're just going to repeat
after me and Arabic okay sure all right
and LA
ilaja Allah
Anna
muhammadan muhammadan
[Music]
now repeat after me in English I bear
witness I bear witness that there is
none worthy of worship that there isn't
say it again that there is none worthy
of worship there is none worthy of
worship except for Allah except for
Allah and I bear witness and I bear
witness that the prophet Muhammad that
the Prophet Muhammad
is the servant is the servant and
messenger of Allah and messenger of
Allah
U Akbar welcome Jared to Islam you now
officially a Muslim that is how easy it
is
that's how beautiful Islam is Yani you
recognize the truth you accept it and
there's no long drawn-out conversion
process you accept that Islam is the
truth you say the shahada you you
declare that this is the truth you
accept one God where they worship in the
prophet Muhammad as his messenger and
you are a Muslim alhamdulillah how do
you feel Jared amazing thank you
of course so
I do want to hear about your story but I
think what might be a little bit better
is that since Colin is here I'll bring
Colin in he will give his shahada as
well because I said we do have two today
in hamdullah and then you can we can all
discuss the three of us
our Journeys and all that stuff so Colin
give me a thumbs up if you're ready to
be brought in all right here we go hello
hey calling my man how you doing bro I'm
good I'm good that's good so brother
Jared here just said his shahada and now
we're gonna help you you know accept
Islam as well so first I'm just gonna
ask you a few very basic questions just
to see if your basic beliefs are in line
with Islam perfect so firstly do you
believe that there's only one God worthy
of worship yes
and do you believe in the angels that
God describes in the Quran yes and do
you believe in the prophets and The
Messengers that God sent to the world I
do and do you believe in the books and
the Revelation that God has sent with
them yes do you believe in
um Divine decree and Destiny from God
yes and do you believe in life after
death and the day of judgment yes
perfect
you're just going to repeat after me can
you see the screen yes all right
ilaha
Allah what is rasulu
now just repeat after me in English I
bear witness I bear witness that there
is none worthy of worship that there is
none worthy of worship except for Allah
except for Allah and I bear witness and
I bear witness that the prophet Muhammad
that the prophet Muhammad is the servant
is the servant and messenger of Allah
and messenger of Allah Allah
two beautiful Brothers have just
accepted Islam you can see you know the
brightness on their face how happy they
are alhamdulillah and this is definitely
a beautiful long time coming a long time
okay so let's get into that so let's
start with you calling then it's been uh
so when I first started uh it was very I
was very ignorant and Islam when I first
like began learning about it I was
actually like
God forgive me but I was making fun of
Muslims because I was so ignorant on it
I thought like the very Western point of
view I thought that they were terrorists
and then my friend had informed me he
said just do your research on it
and the more I did research the more I
said this is genuinely what I believe
wow I always had an issue with
Christianity I was born a Christian I
was baptized when I was young I was
raised in a Christian home but it never
made sense to me
God can't be a human he's Immortal Jesus
died
so it's just I don't know a lot of the a
lot of questions were in Christianity
and that I pose these questions before I
even knew about Islam and it all just
fell in line and it was just perfect for
me
wow so what what were some of the things
that you maybe you you didn't know about
Islam but once you learned you're like
wow you know I didn't even know it was
abrahamic I I didn't even know that it
was they believed in Jesus I didn't know
anything like that like I was so
ignorant on it and so many people are
wow wow very beautifully said so what
message do you have for the people that
maybe were in your shoes a four time ago
when you didn't know much about Islam
just do just just I Islam opened my eyes
to a lot of things I don't believe what
anybody says I do my own research for my
own opinion Islam is very beautiful and
I feel like if you're questioning if you
should convert to Islam I if you feel
like it's true in your heart which it
isn't mine I feel like you should just
do it
that's very beautifully said and what I
really like about your answer is
although you literally just accepted
Islam
you realize that this is not something
where you're like oh just just accept it
you know you don't need evidence you
don't don't need proof it doesn't need
to make sense you know just trust me and
take blind faith and trust that this is
right and you'll be good now Islam is
based on evidence rationality you know
it has to make sense in the Quran Islam
and the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him they're all self-evident you know
they they prove themselves you can
verify these things
so any final words before we pass it on
to brother Jared Colin well the one
thing I will say one uh Quran verse that
really I don't know the verse of the top
but it was about iron
and a lot of people don't talk about the
miracle of iron when it's said that
Allah has sent iron down for mankind and
people don't know that iron actually
came from meteoroids yeah so that is
just like that was mind-blowing to me
like that was like wow how would he know
you know how would Mohammed know if he
wasn't really the messenger of God yeah
that's very beautifully said and you
know subhanallah it's subhanallah means
you know praise be to God it's amazing
because that's one example but there are
so many other things like for example
yes the Egyptian hieroglyphics were lost
for a lot of time like for years they
were lost and then the Rosetta Stone
once we found it it had passages written
in three different languages one is
Egyptian hieroglyphics so they were able
to translate that Rosetta Stone
um and understand hieroglyphics again
so the Quran mentions beautiful someone
with pharaoh named Haman and Pharaoh
asked Haman to build him a staircase
so it gives him a name Haman and
describes him as like kind of an
architect or you know some kind of uh
designer or someone who would you know
design a construction or make a
construction for pharaoh and a man in
the Bible was someone who wasn't even
around at the time of pharaoh he
actually in the Book of Esther worked
for King Xerxes so people would look at
that say look you're just taking names
and switching them and changing history
and we're not going to fall for it but
what do they find when they when they
you know were able to uncover Egyptian
hieroglyphics and understand them again
they went to a list of people who worked
for who we believe was Pharaoh I believe
Ramsay's the second and they found Haman
as a type of architect
how on Earth would the prophet peace
another small example of so many there's
a lot of them every the more research
you do the more you'll find that it
absolutely absolutely so very
beautifully said thank you so much Colin
let's jump to brother Jared now why
don't you tell us a bit about your story
and why you you know decided to accept
Islam
you know very similar to Colin I was
very ignorant to Islam I think mainly
had to do with my my father was a
soldier and he's he fought in Iraq for
many years so there's this distorted
deception on what Muslims are right I
was always told that they're it's an
evil religion you know that these are
bad people so on so forth
and also very similar to Colin like
Christianity never made sense to me I
I've actually
been very tortured inside when it comes
to Christianity ever because my very
first memory of being in church I was
probably four years old if that maybe
three and a half and I went to Sunday
school for the very first time
and uh a little girl had came up to me
and she said hey are you Christian
thinking that she was asking me if that
was my name but I said no I'm and before
I could even say my name Jesus goes oh
you're going hell and that one
experience drifted me away from
Christianity for a very long time wow
and I've tried to reintroduce it back
into my life just because of my family
you know and every single time I've
tried to reintroduce it something just
didn't seem right every time
um I tried going to like a church camp
and I found myself almost basically
lying to myself because I wanted to be
accepted and what I mean by that is uh
when they're singing and doing
everything they raise their hand
symbolizing that they're being saved by
Jesus but I'm this a lone kid right so I
did it myself and then I realized that I
am lying to myself I really don't
believe what they're telling me or what
they're saying
um another and jump forward 18 years old
I go to church again and at this time
I was living with an uncle because I was
a pretty delinquent child to say the
least and I was having substance abuse
issues you know so um
I went again and the very first thing
the pastor came up and told me was
you're not dressed properly for church
well I didn't know there was a dress
code man my bad
so again that was just another bad
experience I tried again at 19 years old
I tried going again and I went to
introduce myself to the pastor it's just
something I always wanted to do you know
just go and talk to the person that's
going to be leading the sermon right and
he said Son you do not realize that you
might go to hell for the tattoos you
have and um and that very and right then
and there I was I was like you know what
maybe this isn't for me
and then about I would say I was 21
years old and
I um I took a heroic dose to say to Lisa
of mushrooms if I'm being completely
honest and
um during this experience I had just a a
very clear voice in me to say follow the
Creator and I don't even know what that
really meant at all but I had gotten a
I got a tattoo to kind of like symbolize
what I'd felt right
um so having the Creator in my life was
the number one thing you know and that's
all I look forward to but I also had an
issue that spiritually about doing this
alone I didn't I didn't want to
praise God by myself because honestly
again I was ignorant to what all was out
there and then uh about two months ago
shout out to the Warner I got
recommended a video from the algorithm
on YouTube and he shared his dawa to the
public right and um I realize that wow
this is actually exactly what I believe
in you know
um
and ever since then I've been quite um
I would say almost borderline obsessed
with wanting to learn more you know what
I mean and um
it's been a beautiful experience so far
like I mentioned to you and on Instagram
that I do read my Quran
every single night at least a couple of
pages you know to educate myself
um but yeah that's
wow I mean wow that's that's a very
powerful story man
I found a lot it actually it makes me a
bit emotional to hear because it just
reminds me how big of a blessing Islam
is you know how much of a blessing Islam
is alhamdulillah
and then um one thing during the Aidan
Ross clip how he was saying how um
religion Christianity or whatever is
fear-driven you know
and uh
I can understand that because every time
I you go to like a Christian church and
they're shouting at you that if you
don't do this you're going to hell blah
blah blah blah and it it can
mess with you mentally you know what I
mean and just like it did me ever since
I was four years old but wow
so with with that being said let me give
you guys a few very beautiful verses
from the Quran a very beautiful facts
about stem so first and foremost
in Islam no matter who or or and who
they are or what they've done in the
past
once they accept Islam they've gone from
a state of ignorance of not knowing to a
state of knowing and accepting Islam so
Allah and the prophet sallam he says in
the Hadith that Islam basically forgives
all sins that when a person first comes
into Islam anything anything that
they've done in the past and the eyes of
Allah is Forgiven so we actually my my
co-host and my brother Angel
he has tattoos he has sleeves of tattoos
um from before he accepted Islam
and he also had people you know try and
jump on him like Hey why you got tattoos
and all whatever but you know these
people are ignorant they don't know that
Allah said already forgiven him for the
tattoos Allah has forgiven him so for
you as well Allah has forgiven you for
your tattoos he does no need to get them
removed and go through that pain and
Allah has forgiven you Allah he says in
the Quran
and once you read the Quran you'll get
to this verse I think it's in Surah
zumar I think it might be 39 I'm not
sure about it says
he says tell my servants
um who have transgressed against their
selves you know by committing sins or
whatever do not despair don't lose hope
in the mercy of Allah indeed Allah
forgives all sins
and it is him who is the most forgiving
and the most merciful now that is Allah
that's our creator the one that created
you and me this is how merciful he is
alhamdulillah man and that's why I
reminded myself first and foremost I'm
about to make myself cry man beautiful
so honestly I think the the best
conversations and podcasts are just the
ones that were naturally so the floor is
all yours anything you guys want to talk
about let's just chop it up inshallah
yeah um just I don't know uh
I'm still very ignorant on a lot of it
so that's why I'll continue like
watching channel you'll learn more and
more and more you know because your
channel that was the main reason that
found out I could you know become
or could convert because I didn't
there's no like mosque around you know I
live in a pretty
on Islamic area of the world so
it was uh it was like and also allow me
I can't really get my hands on that
but I do my best to get like no
antibiotics in the meat and uh I just
try to do my best with all that
that's good man that's good and Allah
you know he knows that you guys have
just accepted us that Allah it doesn't
expect anyone even me I've been
practicing for a few years he doesn't
expect anyone to be perfect right so I'm
gonna still make mistakes today
literally I'm gonna probably walk out of
my room and make a small mistake here
and there you guys are gonna make
mistakes but know that you don't have to
be perfect ASAP
because Allah rewards the person who
when they slip and they commit sins or
they they fall off her gets or mess up
they ask for forgiveness and they intend
to do better and they consistently work
on themselves to be a better version of
themselves and it's actually I think is
beautiful
that Allah has created humans and not
allowed them to reach any kind of
perfection
because we're always striving to be
better for his sake alhamdulillah and
may Allah allow us to do that
you know what has actually like about
Islam that has cleared my conscience
quite a bit is a
so I I have two young kids very little
and my wife was raised as a Catholic and
it took her a very long time to come and
ask me can I do you mind if we uh get
have our children baptized
you know and of course who am I to say
no right this is my wife this is her
belief I think I should respect that and
when I heard that Islam doesn't believe
in the original sin it made me feel so
much better because when I I was pretty
much told that like why are they getting
baptized as babies
and the fear was if something happened
to them as babies they would
go to the Hellfire pretty much and that
that almost kind of destroyed me that
why would that even be a belief with
something so innocent and perfect in our
eyes you know what I mean
um but that's actually helped me so much
that's man that's that's beautiful and
you guys are gonna find and you know
it's it's crazy because even today there
are things that I've I'm learning
literally like you know in the last few
days that I hear and I just like I'm
astonished
um I was watching I just I discussed
this earlier I don't know if you guys um
uh were listening in but there's a video
on a channel named blogging Theology and
um he was hosting a session with Dr
um Ali atai who is a scholar PhD and he
understands Arabic Hebrew and Greek and
he was explaining
how Jesus not being crucified is an
actual is actually a plausible
historical
um you know outlook on what what
happened and it goes through the the
passion narratives of Jesus dying for
the sin and all that stuff and he
basically dismantles them and he quotes
other authorities who have said that you
know this piece here was taken from this
piece of Greek folklore earlier and you
know Mark was a really good Storyteller
because there are certain things that
culturally did not make sense that he
had to put it in for example a tomb
above ground it doesn't make sense for
Jesus to be buried below ground because
how is anyone going to see the tomb is
empty what had to be above ground this
is against their tradition of giving a
and where did the Tomb come from it
actually was donated from someone who
didn't even know Jesus but
just decided to give it the lead there's
a lot of things that don't make sense
but they're really good stories so when
you look at it from that perspective you
know my heart feels the same thing that
your guys's Hearts feel when you're like
wow that makes sense that's what I
believe that makes sense
so
man it's beautiful it really is
ever since I started doing research on
Islam I feel like like Allah has been
like showing me like I never used to
dream and ever since I've been dreaming
about like things I was unsure about he
was like telling me like this is what
you should do got me a good job like
everything like it's it's insane like
the more I learn the more I know that
that's true
yeah go on in the uh I'm right there
with him the past two and I have three
months or so pretty much
from the video that I watched with the
Warner I I quit smoking cigarettes cold
turkey
uh it it was rough for like 48 hours but
I just continued to like pray with
myself continue to go
still I don't smoke I smoked marijuana
for probably 14 years of my life New
Year's Eve quit that
um and uh basically trying to take
myself more seriously as a person take
care of myself spiritually and
physically you know and uh
without
researching and doing all this I don't
think I'd still be in the same Loop of I
guess I would say almost
self-destruction in a sense you know wow
wow subhanallah and you know
that's the difference between you know
Islam and something like liberalism
because liberalism
tells people to maximize their own
personal freedom and to go for whatever
you know pleases them to go for their
own pleasure so people when they smoke a
cigarette they're like you know they get
a good Buzz or they get a good feeling
or it takes the edge off or whatever you
know they feel but that's an instant
gratification you become addicted it
becomes harmful and then long term
you're really literally just killing
yourself I shouldn't say that word on
live but you're really over time harming
your body Islam believes in prevention
not not some kind of cure or treatment
after you hurt yourself it says don't
hurt yourself to begin with so Islam
would not allow such a thing but where
we grow up they're like listen we don't
care if you if you offer yourself after
30 years of living
um if you live the the best 30 years of
your life
um it's very sad it's very hedonistic
but I've also been
so much a way better husband to my wife
in the past two and a half months also
uh I treated her more like a queen like
a lot of says so
um this might even be a little
embarrassing to say but like
masturbation isn't even attractive
anymore to me I
you know any of those kind of desires
I've completely have washed for myself
and
um that's been a beautiful experience
also I didn't really know how much
connection I was really missing until I
just threw everything away and I guess
put everything in a lot of hands you
know
that's beautiful honestly honestly it's
kind of like I don't know what else to
say except that's beautiful you know
that's that's what Islam does that's
what belief in Allah does that person it
gives them an understanding of why
you know why am I going to avoid this
thing if it gives me pleasure and why am
I gonna do this thing if it's like a
little tedious or a little difficult
it's because the the thing in actually
uh summer Allah is in the Quran says you
may love a thing which is bad for you
and you may hate a thing which is good
for you you don't know in Allah knows
that's literally my whole point
summarizing a few words but one thing I
want to make mention of is there are two
I guess two types of tests from Allah
you know one is a test of when he gives
you things that we see as abundance
goodness you know a lot of money or a
good job or a good spouse or children or
so on and so forth and the other test is
the opposite where Allah restricts
something from you he takes something
from you he takes money he takes a
family member he he takes your job away
you know things like that that we see as
negative
he describes when he when he tests a
person and he gives them and after he
says and when he tests a person and he
takes away from them describes them both
as tests so in your life in your lives
you guys will experience difficulty
and you will experience you know you
know Glad Tidings and good things and
and abundance
but the prophet peace upon him he told
us how to deal with both and he said it
in a very beautiful way he said how
amazing is the state of a Believer how
amazing is it that when he's when he's
basically given something good he's
given goodness and abundance he's
grateful to Allah and that's better for
him and when he's given something that's
difficult
he's patient and that is better for him
meaning that when Allah gives you
something he gives you a million dollars
and you instantly go alhamdulillah thank
you Allah and you're consciously
constantly consistently grateful to
Allah you're getting more Good Deeds for
the fact that you are blessed and you
think you're grateful to Allah and when
you're being tested he takes something
away and you're patient saying Allah
will take me out of the situation Allah
will make this easier Allah will take
this away then you're getting rewarded
just for that patience subhanallah you
know we're all men we go out we work
probably if you have a physically or or
mentally emotionally draining job when
you get home and your head hurts you get
home and your back hurts Allah is
rewarding you for that so long as you
have the right intentions Allah is
rewarding you for even those things
alhamdulillah
so I don't want because a few Rivers you
know sometimes they accept the stem it's
only difficult happens to them like oh
my God there's a sign they shouldn't be
a Muslim this is a sign that Allah loves
you because there's another Hadith when
he said that when Allah intends a person
to be raised in status in a way that
they basically are not going to bring
themselves to by doing good or whatever
Allah tests them
because that test is is basically going
to basically erase some of their bad
Deeds ex be some of their bad deeds and
give them good deeds for being patient
and so on and so forth so being tested
sometimes alhamdulillah is beautiful and
last thing I'm going to say because I
know I spoke a lot I've been testing
alhamdulillah a good bit in the last few
years I'm going to be honest
but it has not been anywhere close to
when I was tested and I I wasn't
thinking of Allah and I didn't have the
outlook on Islam and I don't want to get
into details but like if I was given
this test years ago I would have
crumbled I would have crumbled like
nothing honestly but I wasn't even
scared to be honest
I wasn't even scared of whatever outcome
might happen because I just knew that
Allah was going to take care of it
alhamdulillah it seems like Allah did
sure
kind of reminds me of a quote from Mike
Tyson he says
God sometimes punish you it punishes you
by giving you everything you ever want
just to see how you handle it yeah yeah
I think Mike Tyson actually be a Muslim
I don't know if he's too practicing but
he went to um to omara recently actually
traveled to to the Kaaba in Mecca and
Saudi Arabia and so on and so forth so
um alhamdul I think he's a Muslim as
well yeah yeah definitely
subhanallah all right I think this has
been a tremendous stream alhamdulillah
and this has been such a beautiful way
to end it uh do you guys have any final
thoughts or notes for the audience
hmm no I'm okay I think that's about it
I gotta do some research and like to
properly praying that's the one thing I
know I gotta do
yeah don't worry inshallah we're going
to uh we're gonna get you guys situated
we're gonna discuss what the next steps
are and hopefully get you set up with
you know your muscle your musk and your
your local mosque in the community and
or at least somebody online who can walk
you through and help you with this okay
all right of course and Jared my man how
about you any final words
um
the search for the truth and the truth
will come to you I believe that's what I
did
and not work for me yes sir
absolutely guys may Allah bless you both
the message inshallah we will definitely
touch base afterwards and I'll see you
guys soon thank you for having me
of course it's our pleasure
my heart
is soft it's softened it's mush
alhamdulillah
foreign
what else is there to say
and with that being said
Allah